[Music]
in his new book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds michael knowles examines where
political correctness
came from michael knowles author and
host of the michael knowles show
joins us now to discuss hi michael
welcome to the show
thanks for having me it's great to be
with you michael tell us what your
book's about
so this book is a the second book that
i've published the first book with words
and it's actually a book about words
it's a book about
how the left has generally the left
though i have some barbs for the right
as well
has manipulated language to control our
culture
and our discourse and so it it provides
a century-long history of what we call
political correctness
or wokeness or cancer culture and it
examines what what i think is the
central trap of political correctness
namely conservatives have been fighting
against this thing for 30 years
and we only ever seem to lose ground we
haven't even managed to conserve the
women's bathroom
and i think the reason for this is that
we misunderstand what pc
really is we view it as a battle between
free speech on the one hand
and censorship on the other but really i
think it's
a battle of competing sets of standards
and i think the leftist
theorists who were often very brilliant
who developed this thing they understood
that and it's why they've been able to
manipulate and wield language much more
effectively
to reconstitute the political order
well it makes sense to me that that
conservatives would be continually
losing this battle because
conservatives are always wanting to stay
the same
so they're always kind of the party you
know the the side of resistance the side
of
stop no don't pull and then the left
will continue pulling and pulling and
pulling and
sometimes it feels like you're
definitely pulling teeth but
inch by inch we kind of get society to
move a little bit more in a direction
that is more enlightened or progressive
or whatever but
so i mean it seems to me like it would
make sense that conservatives would
always lose this because you're not
really fighting
for something you're just resisting well
this reminds me of chesterton's
observation that it's the job of the
liberal to go about making mistakes
and the job of the conservative to make
sure those mistakes are never corrected
and i think that's probably closer to
your description of it but but i don't
think it's quite right i i don't think
that
i certainly don't want to keep the
society exactly the same as it is now i
think it's basically in ruins at the
moment
so i would like to return to a culture
of say life i would like to
make abortion illegal i'd like to have a
more sensible
and reality based definition of what sex
is we can no longer
even just discern between men and women
i would like a much more serious and
traditional definition of marriage
i would like a society that recognizes
and respects the middle class and maybe
pushes for a little bit more
manufacturing in this country actually
producing something
beyond shipping our jobs overseas i'd
like stronger borders i'd like a whole
lot of things
that we don't have right now but even
when we want pretty
significant changes we still lose
on those issues by the way even when the
majority of americans on certain issues
like for instance
voter id or on border enforcement even
when the majority of americans are with
us
we still lose and i think it's because
we have lost the institutions that wield
political power
and and we've lost in some way the the
ability to communicate because the left
by manipulating language very often wins
debates even before they begin
you know there's a lot of um i i think
there's a lot
written and talked about on the subject
of like
cancel culture wokeness etcetera i have
a book about
the campus free speech issue there are
many other books of
you know similar silenced censored
speechless etc
um we've i think we've talked this
problem almost to death the problem of
the progressive left having an
intolerance for
ideas they disagree with and and i i
mean you're right trying to use language
or trying to change the meanings of
words so you can't even talk about
things
in like a very orwellian sense uh but
what
maybe we i don't think we've maybe we've
maybe you've done this in your book
have we correctly diagnosed where this
comes from before we can even understand
how to stop it
no i think the difference with my book
is that i think cancel culture is a
perfectly fine thing
most of these books say you know cancel
culture is terrible and it's brand new
and we've got to get rid of it
but i don't think it's new at all i
think that all societies have standards
all societies inevitably have taboos the
united states
has outlawed or otherwise suppressed all
forms of speech from the very beginning
of our country through the present
and so what has happened is not so much
that we now have less free speech today
than we used to have in some ways we
have more free speech you know
all the seven words that george carlin
said we could never say on tv
now i think we almost are required to
say them on tv but we're not allowed to
make
perfectly plain observations about
nature you know about men and women or
babies or whatever else
uh because then you'll be labeled as
some sort of bigot or some misinformer
so i i think that the key here is that
we had canceled culture in the 1950s in
the 1950s
you would be canceled for being a
communist today we have cancer culture
and you'll be canceled for not being a
communist
the thing that has changed is not that
there is a cancer culture or standards
or taboos
the the thing that's changed is what
those standards are and the left i think
has understood that and and changed
those standards and i think we need to
engage with that as well and i think
seriously we could learn something from
the left well doesn't that become a
little
uninteresting at some point though that
like the people i disagree with
uh should be cancelled and the people i
like should not be canceled is there a i
mean is there a principle to that
there is the principle is the good the
true and the beautiful i think
i i know that it's very popular now in
some corners of the right
to pretend that drag queen story hour is
one of the blessings of liberty which is
by you can hear james madison rolling
over in his grave by the way
but i don't think it is and the founding
fathers would not have thought that
either
they did not conflate as we do today
liberty and licentiousness
and even the argument that that people
make on both the left and the more
moderate right
when they say that if we ban say drag
queen story hour
that the left will prevent us from going
to church on sunday i say first of all
they've already been preventing us from
going to church on sunday they spent
much of last year doing that
but but second of all if we really
cannot discern
between a pervert twerking for a toddler
at the public library
and a pastor preaching the gospel if we
really think those things
are absolutely on the same level then
what we have done
is conceded our faculties of reason and
our moral conscience we're saying
that we can't discriminate between true
and false and good and bad and right and
wrong and if that's the case
then we can't have self-government which
relies on those faculties it's that's
what john adams means when he says
the constitution's built for moral and
religious people if if we really can't
discern between good and bad then
self-government's not possible
do you think that we're just sort of
trading in tolerances i mean it seem you
know you mentioned the
50s and you you cancel communism and you
mentioned now
you're canceled if you're not a
communist but then you also bring up
that you would like
to ban abortions or you would like to
return to
certain norms and sort of banning i mean
essentially that would be
a different brand of intolerance i mean
so one side right now i do agree that
there's a lot of
leftist or liberal or whatever you want
to call this particular group
intolerance but i feel like it's more of
just trading it out
so we would just trade for conservative
intolerance well is that a threat do you
think
well if you make any moral claim if
you're going to have any society at all
then you need to
encourage the good and discourage the
bad that's the most basic way society
governs itself
i think of john locke the father of
liberalism in the letter concerning
toleration he says we need broad
toleration
but atheists need to be suppressed john
milton and eriopogitica most famous
defense of free speech
in the english language he says we need
to tolerate everybody but catholics need
to be suppressed i'm glad we've changed
that standard because otherwise i would
not be able to speak with you right now
but what what they were acknowledging is
that all societies
liberty itself necessarily entails
limits i mean even just
the fact that we are using language to
communicate with one another
words mean one thing they don't mean the
other thing and so
i think for instance the radical leftist
herbert marcuza
father of the new left when he says
tolerance cannot tolerate
intolerance he's right i mean he's
making an observation you can't you
can't have a society that's going to
completely
undermine itself so what i'm not even
making a prescriptive statement so much
as i'm i'm making a descriptive
observation
that all societies are going to tolerate
some things and not tolerate other
things
and this has always been true in america
it's been true in every country in the
history of the world
and so while the left is willing to
actually craft that overton window and
those standards or whatever you want to
call it
the right has been dithering and
twiddling our thumbs and
refusing to engage which is why we've
consistently lost
thanks so much for talking with us
michael great to be with you both
you